well I come again and welcome again so
that's good hey welcome to this video
and super Sasha mark becker which if i'm
not wrong which is wrong no I'm right
okie dokie yeah a modern defense or yeah
we stay within the the modern defense
how can I do many 50 is this a bad
version of the Queen trade well it's
probably not a brilliant version but
it's not clear that is actually going to
take no it's not doing that just want to
try to get a quick pressure on d4 but
this still has not he can just cancel oh
I'm start doing that so we're going to
get a kind of Kings Indian after all but
he has played c3 and c4 this doesn't
look so great young
now sometimes those kind of g6 thing
setups candy too very nice versions of
the Kings Indian web Blackman has some
gas some some some some some moves
gained or some of the benefits yeah I'm
should have yeah I have some some extra
some extra time gained okay so go into
2d kun can just trade only form trying
to open up the position special 1g5 is
slightly annoying also night age 59 f 4
maybe but okay let's sit let's do it do
it in a simple fashion and maybe it
takes with the bishop and build annoyed
but I don't know the main idea is that I
want to use my development here and take
yeah and then Bishop f5 was my idea
trying to after takes GTX then play
Queen D 796
okay so what you wants to do is you want
to try to keep us the control will over
you for with the piece which is very
understandable 92 is one key idea so
let's see maybe a + 92 now only thinking
after the caption e7 okay it's not doing
anything in that regard
just activating on the earth hub now no
92 obviously blunders the bishop so if
he wants to prepare that he has to spend
some time by Bishop is potentially is
still a bad piece on g7 so I have to be
a little bit a little bit wary about
that but okay taking him and now i have
bishop age 6 which was my IDM that is
not going to easily get this in can take
i can also do this first it's no real
good square where you can put it okay
yeah but this is this is actually quite
okay for black now i got good activity
on the FL it's not so clear what whites
plan is I mean it's not like I'm better
but I definitely don't have any problem
now maybe I should have just taken c4
right and now i will take it come on
this is not really a compensation or is
it how to believe
that's hard to believe okay opening the
C file there is some play of the slip on
the c forum that you might get but still
um yeah Brooksie five this before which
is kind of embarrassing look Dee for
Queen takes d4 is even more embarrassing
so I'm going to go back to that form and
now is trying to pile up and came here
for look deform probably or for reform
yeah for root deform it's probably good
to trying to get this play against the
deep on going yeah and I also have a
four I was thinking that maybe i have
some tactic on the FR but that doesn't
seem to be any so I'm going for the porn
him trying to win the pawn 25 rooks is
seven no there is no way around that
give this chick it's not helping very
much and go to f2 can take a tool but
Queen age 6 is Sam is a problem
check check look f7 was my idea just
simple simply trying to trade of this
rook draw a third time morning why I
don't see it raw
not sure maybe yes some compensation or
no but it's still upon he's got one
minute more on the clock but okay I'm
used to that it's not like this is a new
experience check now it's got the sea
farm it's definitely not like an easy
win or anything definitely not
maybe this one yeah I don't see a direct
way for him to do something and I'm
opening up against his King as well
which is kind of helpful Queen to e5 is
also good Queen d6 a steak f3 he's no
direct attack when you form interesting
oh well okay check yeah this is so this
is at least draw for him Jackie not
really avoided or can i I really don't
see how probably not him check check
yeah in 19 seconds he can he can just
force the draw it's nothing that I can
do ah 24 the strong move I mean maybe he
has probably enough play anyway or hear
a baby not taking okay I don't need to
take yeah well computers roastiness just
goes age five and says black is better
it still looks at kind of shaking yeah
right okay this is a self Pena that she
cannot go group c eight this is kinda
understand the way if i get to take on
your 3 i'm definitely just better with
the pawn yeah complicated it was was was
very in high city gave me the bond maybe
i should have taken it immediately this
is also really good but it's probably a
matter of being really precise to
convert this because the counter play
can't come quickly the computer gives
this which is pretty strong maybe
threatening this so and if you go here
I'm just much more active now attacking
all kinds of pawns
and here I just rook c8 and then taking
that makes lots of sense right just
trade one look in the process check yeah
I'm better but that's not clear that I'm
that I can do much in terms of winning
yeah there was most difficult probably
pretty fair result I mean I made my
mistakes as well okay well thanks for
watching